de suite cyril payen notre envoyé
spécial sur le pont dire pin symbole de
la résistance les ukrainiens sont
toujours mobilisés est convaincu qu'ils
vont gagner la guerre
effectivement et particulièrement ici
sur ce pont dont les images on s'en
souvient il ya deux mois on fait sans
doute le tour du monde puisque ici vous
le disait très bien c'est un des grands
symboles de cette résistance sept
régions résidentielles dire pine beach à
et au sto mail qui est d'abord on fait
briser ont détruit ce pont qui était une
voie d'accès au centre de kif et tous et
ouest de la capitale kiev et bien qui
c'est entrer en résistance alors que
l'ensemble de la capitale kiev était
encerclée ici c'est sans doute la clé du
à la raison pour laquelle aujourd'hui à
kiev on essaie de reprendre une vie où
un semblant de vie normale donc ce pont
est détruit
comme un symbole aussi au nom des ses
milliers de réfugiés qui sont passés un
jour après jour en dépit des
bombardements intenses que nous avons
vécu ici il ya quelques semaines alors
qu'il faisait extrêmement froid où il
neigeait ce pont de bois qui a été
construit par des volontaires va être
conservé cet endroit va être pas
reconstruit mais utilisé comme un comme
un mausolée comme un grand un grand
symbole de cette de cette résistance
donc c'est là où ça se passe mais
c'était exactement aussi là qu'il ya
encore une grande actualité puisque on
parle évidemment des crimes de guerre
pourquoi pas le pro le président heinz
qui a évoqué le crime de génocide
pointer du doigt l'invasion aux
militaires russes et c'est donc derrière
moi à haïr pin à bout de chasteaux mail
qu'il y a des dizaines
d'enquêteurs dont d'une vingtaine de
français qui recueille jour après jour
et bien les preuves de ces crimes de
guerre les preuves qui sont assez
complète puisque en fait les endroits
qui sont juste derrière moi sont parfois
dans certains quartiers détruits à 80 ce
qu à 15% c'est absolument incroyable que
le taux de destruction mais aussi des
histoires assez terrible des témoignages
que nous commençons à recueillir de
viols de masse de gens qui ont été
séquestrés
d'exécutions arbitraires de civils et
d'ailleurs pour en témoigner sur la
colline qui se trouve juste ici recettes
direction il ya un cimetière civil où il
ya des centaines de tombes frêche qui
sont en fait des cimetières quand ils
sont peu plus aujourd'hui de centaines
de civils qui ont été ses victimes
collatérales de cette région qui encore
une fois a sans doute sauvé kiev d'être
envahis complètement parle par l'armée
russe merci beaucoup cyril payen merci à
vous